[Music]
believe on Easter why speak the truth
hello and welcome back to game sports
coverage of The Witcher 3 in the last
video we introduced the world of The
Witcher its cities villages and
landscapes but today we're gonna unveil
the gameplay of Wild Hunt it's
fascinating use of branching storylines
that impact on the main quest its new
open-world structure its new systems for
leveling and potions and a Pokemon style
collectible card game tournament yeah
really
alright we've got a lot to talk about so
let's get stuck in The Witcher games are
linear role-playing series we're making
decisions at key moments makes the story
branch from time to time even in simple
conversations making decisions is key to
The Witcher choosing the lesser of two
evils this is the core of The Witcher
experience and it's retained in Wild
Hunt
but Wild Hunt is also an open-world game
with dozens upon dozens of side quests
many of which you'll be making tough
decisions into and in today's video
while tiptoeing around story specifics
lead quest designer Mateus Tomas kovitch
is going to help us dive into what
exactly you'll be doing during your time
in Carol's shoes we are very focused on
the storyline so on the story of Geralt
of Steel II and the yellow herd but as
we develop the game we have designed
these sites quest lines that were
connected very strongly with the main
storyline but we're branching off from
it so to speak so as you will progress
through the main storyline
you will find that you can continue or
ignore like these big story lines of
local places or hubs of important
characters that you meet what's the
famous Jenga fret neither Witcher 4 so
the main game is around eight to ten
main story quests but each of these
involves are in two or three branching
secondary quests so for instance earlier
in our game while trying to discover a
piece of valuable information I was
pointed in the direction of two people
who might have it
a local baron and a witch in a distant
town both of these were large quests in
their own right that took at least over
an hour each but as they reach their
conclusions and I received the
information I needed to complete the
first part of my main question these
quests didn't necessarily end I was free
to leave and continue the
Qwest if I so wished or I could continue
then this branching secondary questline
but it's the way in which the secondary
quests impact the main storyline that's
really fascinating ignoring those can
can cause some consequences in the world
as well as I mean participating in those
it wasn't as if I was forced to complete
the secretary quest then and there but
clearly these quests will impact on the
main storyline in some form or another
it almost felt like the optional
missions in Mass Effect 2 which
eventually had dire consequences on the
main storyline
it just wasn't explicitly explained how
this is how the witcher 3 embraces its
open-world the core story branches out
dragging into new areas back across
familiar land so you never quite know
where you're going next as you roam from
place to place you gather quests from
noticeboards and towns from random
encounters and from exploring the
wilderness
[Music]
if you decide to take on with your
contract in some village
the villagers later on might react
differently on yellow depending on what
he did in this contract
there are also some side quests that are
basically stories in themselves so I
think they are interesting for the
players they will be interesting for the
players you can never quite bank on side
quests in many open-world games all too
often they're generic or repetitive or
too short so during our time myself and
producer Andy baman ran all over the map
to see what we could discover we don't
want to get into spoilery specifics over
what we saw and did but Mateus was all
too happy to give us a decent overview
we also have Southwest Kuna and they are
not simple contracts if you take from
the notice border from the quest giver
we have also some encounters and quests
that happen basically as you pass them
you will have this feeling that things
happen around Geralt while he travels
through this world that it's living
breathing we'll some of these side
quests are short some are part of longer
quest chains but the ones we played had
multiple gameplay elements conversations
tracking hunting and so on but perhaps
the most interesting about these side
quests is that they're leveled while
many open-world games like to hide
mission progression behind ability
barriers a while there's a tendency in
fantasy games to enable the NPC's to
level up alongside the player character
The Witcher 3 has a straight-up MMO
style quest leveling system so as we ran
around the world at level 4 probably
around five hours in we ran into quests
as high as level 33 we heard they
reached up to 50 while it looks like
Geralt himself can reach level 60 and
with the expansion packs on the horizon
we heard that these levels will likely
increase and also this means that once
the main story is complete you'll
probably still have a bunch of quests to
do we were tempted to balance it in a
way that you simply go through from the
level to level and they are all or
evened out for your level but we thought
that something is getting lost in
between you know I mean if I know it
might feel irritating maybe or it might
feel weird when you encounter when you
level at 6 or 5 and the encounter level
to a quest but I think this is something
that players will come back to later on
in the game if of course they will play
that long and I think this is something
to do in the so called endgame yeah and
it's not an MMO obviously but as I said
previously you can play after credits we
don't want you to have this feeling that
you have to complete all side content
before you engage in main storyline for
me it works like this in some games with
playing especially open-world games yeah
I hold up playing a main storyline I do
all the side quests if I can it's like
the ends then I come back and I'm like
okay what was it about and we wanted to
avoid that very strongly because the
main storyline is very important for us
but all this monster hunting can be
bloody exhausting why not take a load
off
sit down with a body in place of cards
Gwen's may look like some boring ass
card minigame but trust us for a minute
CD Projekt are doing some weird stuff
here well basically Gwent was present in
the books in The Witcher books and this
is something that we always wanted to
have in the games basically you can
gather these cards in the world you can
buy them you can win them from the
players of course you have quest lines
about it you have this huge tournament
lived when yeah yeah and like even if
you can pokemon or magic the object the
gathering like pokemon i mean we don't
have this one quest that makes you know
our jokes about it in novigrad i don't
want to spoil too much every situation
where you can say okay look if I beat
you in Gwen so you'll have to do what I
want without spoiling and the thing I
could say yeah all right that sounds
pretty cool
[Applause]
of course it's not all about Geralt of
Rivia from time to time you'd also get
to play as gerelds protege ciri who's on
the run these are linear episodes which
pop in from time to time during the main
quest as far as we know either actually
gets a player in the open world but then
we've barely scraped the surface ciri is
mostly involved in the main storyline
the sections that we play see we are
basically closed off you can't explore
the open world as Siri you didn't see
everything yet from her abilities
basically he develops as you play the
game also she gets stronger later on in
the game it's fair to say that the
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt has a lot going on
and it should a few weeks ago there were
news reports detailing that the game had
over 200 hours of gameplay from our time
with the game I could certainly see that
this could be the case but what's
crucial and where many open world games
fall short is that the gameplay needs to
keep being engaging there are a lot of
gameplay elements in Wild Hunt but it's
had a combine that gives a game like
this longevity we asked Matias how
important he felt this was we tried to
include all different the gameplay
elements no requests to make player to
keep players interested in in the game
and as we got these new tools these new
tools of transportation we try to
incorporate incorporate them in the
quests as well you will have horse races
we don't have boat races but there are
some quests that involve sailing limbo
there are quests that will make you dive
underwater and find stuff like hidden
coves hidden caves we were trying to do
everything we can for the players to
appeal this awesome basically this
awesome feeling of exploration of this
rich world we didn't want the players to
feel that okay there are the quests
right and you can go on the quest path
but don't go on the sides because there
is nothing there no we wanted to do to
make everything we can that it feels
like living breathing world
rich with things to find interesting to
explore basically GameSpot doesn't just
pony up the cash and resources to fly
across the world to check out any game
but from myself and Andy's time playing
it in Warsaw from our time talking to
the developers it's clear to see that
the Witcher 3 Wild Hunt has all the
makings or the ingredients of a really
special game whether it is or not I
guess we'll just have to wait and see
the game comes out on PC and current gen
consoles May 19th
[Music]